in the beginning of the show people
commented that a portion got dropped or
deleted like it just I was talking about
Biden getting ready it was gone and
we've had so many of these kind of
things happen that I don't believe they
can be coincidences because it's just it
happens a lot so someone just super
chatted that they just started watching
and in the beginning the intro was cut
like you can't actually hear me talk
about what happened with Biden but we
talk about them again and again and
again throughout this show I want to
tell everybody what happened with
turning point us X I'm not sure we ever
actually talked about it but when we
went live with Turning Point USA you may
have noticed we were late
we weren't late actually we were on time
the stream started right on time and
then what happened started remember
there you guys were like it it says
we're live but we're not coming up
nothing's right right yeah yeah it was
it was live to us and it's live in my
feeds and but nobody could see it they
were like where's the show the show's
delayed right and then I got messages
and they were like people were telling
me after the show they were like hey the
show didn't go up for like 10 minutes
but we were live streaming on our end
everything was going through and I'm
wondering if you know we had Charlie
Kirk we had Bannon we had James Lindsay
we had lucrutkowski you and me I'm
wondering if the people at YouTube were
like boss what do we do Tim Poole Bannon
Kirk lukerkowski Ian James are on stage
in a massive stadium with thousands of
seats and they're gonna talk at this
massive convention
what do we do with this and then they
were like holding pattern and then they
watched us and they were like okay
they're gonna holding pattern let me get
confirmation from the boss as to what to
do and they were like Let It Go Let It
Go I'm wondering if any if anyone else
did something like this like these kind
of that that exact conversation were to
happen I'd imagine they would have
gotten a strike and they've gotten
banned but I wonder if YouTube was
scared like we cannot defend against a
lawsuit from from turning point from
Steve Bannon and from from Tim Poole all
at the same time over this and because
they're on stage at the at this massive
Convention Center the the pr damage from
taking the show down would be so massive
but so that's that's a possibility Elon
Musk needs to buy YouTube yeah good luck
but the reason I think it's it's
possible it's possible that they've got
their thumb on the scale is because
you guys who watch the show consistently
know this there was one episode where
Luke started talking about the CIA and
then the stream cut off wow yep dropped
off like Luke made some specific points
and then stream just stops and then
kicks back in a few seconds later and
people are like what did Luke just say
what was he saying and that's literally
what happens now and it happens a lot
maybe maybe it's just like a random
glitch that happens yeah Perhaps Perhaps
it could be that would happens a lot but
it doesn't happen during like we're
talking about a TV show it doesn't
happen we're talking about Quantum Mania
or Thanos or anything like that it's own
specific topics only when we're like the
intelligence agencies are doing this
thing and drop but it could happen at
other times we just wouldn't know
because no one would say anything
because we weren't talking about
anything right and it also I'd also see
that the drop frames would tell me that
like we're dropping frames in like a
huge number it would tell me that it's
not doing that but behind the scenes at
mines I would tell you that don't don't
assume malfeasance if there's technical
glitches it's very easily like AWS is
acting up your servers are you know I
don't they're transferring data from one
server to another I'm done believing
it's all just a mistake yeah right we've
been talking about censorship and big
tech for seven eight years now or long I
mean longer actually maybe even nine
years Luke was getting demonetized
before anyone knew what the word was
someone was manually go check this out
we all know what it means to be
demonetized on YouTube these days you
got a little dollar sign icon on your
video you go and one day it's yellow and
it says you know ads Limited
when Luke from we are change was making
videos this is back in like 2011 I'm
hanging out with him and then one day
he's like dude my ads are turned off
again and in his account the little
green icon it was a circle back then is
greyed out he'd have to go back in the
video and activate it again then he'd
come back later and they'd all be gray
again and he'd go in and turn them on
turn them on turn them on turn them on
because there was no formal
demonetization process yeah someone at
Google or YouTube was manually axing his
account and taking ads off of each
individual video so we know that was
happening then then they created the
system to automate it now we have this
I look I I went and hung out at the
offices of Ustream back in the day do
you guys remember yeah we used to stream
on that yeah yeah with the letter U
that's where Joe Rogan started streaming
wasn't it he used to do no no experience
on Ustream and they had guys sitting at
a table with a bunch of computers
computers and on the monitors there
would be like 50 live streams all going
at once and they would and I'm like what
is this and they're like we basically
just watch all of it and if someone
looks like they're becoming a problem we
move them over into this panel on the
left and then basically they they they
look for people who are about to break
the rules or they think might break the
rules take them from the main grid and
put them in the select box and then if
that person takes their shirt off or
does something they nuke it right away
take the stream right down yeah I know
YouTube has that
right YouTube has to have way more
sophisticated tools than that yeah they
probably have ai watching language I
wouldn't even be surprised if they have
ai reading voice Cadence so if you start
to get agitated it can tell yep and
that's so the trick is to just deliver
horrible messages
don't move your eyebrows yeah very very
well I think they have humans who watch
and for a show like this as big as it is
I'm willing to bet that there's like 10
shows and they have like one guy who's
watching all at the same time or more
importantly I'm willing to bet for a
show this big they have one guy who
who's hired to watch the show at least
one guy probably one person and they're
like because your show Rogan show and a
few others yeah any big live streams
will probably not on YouTube anymore oh
right true yeah but uh but all the big
live streams I suppose I can only say
don't I agree with you don't believe
that nothing is going on but just don't
believe anything about it don't believe
that it's people there twisting knobs
don't believe that it's the data getting
corrupted like there's no way to know so
there's no point in coming in with a
strong belief on it but I would like to
know I would say it seems highly
probable
that is the case yeah
honestly it does let's use when I'm
watching this it seems fine all the time
and then I will see comments about you
know I'm not getting it recommended I
haven't I have a couple accounts on my
phone and I check and make sure I'm
still getting any notifications and
sometimes I don't get notifications some
of those accounts and sometimes I do get
notifications of shows live on some
accounts so but I mean the Turning Point
USA thing was really weird yeah because
I get off the stage and then I'm told
immediately the show didn't go live for
like 10 minutes it didn't go live very
stressful for the rest of us backstage
being like what is happening because we
could see it in the monitors but we you
know like the first thing I did was pull
up on YouTube and and you think maybe
there'll be a 30 second delay right like
you think it's a big show I don't
remember how long our lag is anyways
whatever like it doesn't kick in and we
all sort of turn to each other like when
was it this was uh how long ago was it
December two months yeah a couple months
agenda November
15th yeah
fairly recent as a quick aside the poll
says uh people think the FBI ran and 55
say it was a cover-up 45 say deep State
removal but uh again we had we we had on
more than one occasion Luke would start
talking about the intelligence agencies
and things they've done and then all of
a sudden the show dropped for like 20
seconds or something we could double
blind test on Rumble I mean that's
that's some advice is we could try a
different platform and see if it happens
again and the other thing is it happens
spottily and it could be not even
alphabet the company it could be like
well now and continue talking about the
CIA and the FBI and see if it drops off
yeah I don't know it is definitely
certain topics it's definitely topic
based I'm loathe to go that direction to
start assuming for sure that it's
because of the topic yeah I can
understand why you would be I get it and
you have you honestly have more uh you
know experience with this than I would
but to in my experience it seems like
it's topic based and what I've seen and
in the past I've watched a show for
years it definitely seems like there's
you know can you guys listening uh
admitting at YouTube right now Super
Chat us and let us know there are Tech
Technologies I'm using to mute and oh
there's things they have to have it just
let us know you know how I I guarantee
you I I I would say there is no less
than a 100 chance they have that ability
you know why because a crackpot
psychopath live streamed himself going
into a church in New Zealand right right
that kind of stuff has happened before
it's happened more than once and I'm
sure when that happened to every big
Tech platform said we need the ability
to instantly shut down any stream game
we need robot AI whatever tracking
noises YouTube has a rule that you
cannot do anything with guns live
so if you don't so if you if you're on
YouTube and you have a gun Channel you
can go out to your range and do
tutorials and like um
um who's that uh who's what's that gun
Channel Hickok45 I think is a good one
yeah you ever seen it yeah and so
everything that's all fine and they're
like yeah you can do that's totally fine
because it's recording not live though
right yeah and it has to be in the
proper setting so it can only be at a
gun shop to display the weapon or it can
be on the Range where it's safe
so I'm willing to bet they've got
workers and Ai and I bet the workers get
alerted when the AI flag something right
yeah and there's also a lot of pressure
from all of these different
organizations with a lot of money
um on social media platforms to censor
content to you know go after
discrimination hate speech uh violence
Etc so you know what about remember all
those uh Facebook uh sensors who are not
necessarily sensors but they I think
they would be considered sensors they
were watching Facebook material and so
there's uploaded to Facebook to check it
for what wasn't that a whole big story
and that kind of disappeared they were
talking about how it was you know
detrimental to their health how they
could like they were watching so much
negative content all the time and it was
like damaging them remember that well
Ian did it too yeah I did a video about
that in 2018 that was start right after
that idea broke 2017 when people started
coming out they'll hire people to look
at the darkest drags if you mean I mean
stuff would go up on YouTube are you
talking about the tick tock lawsuit I'm
so sorry oh no problem no no I'm talking
about like because there was a tick tock
it's on Facebook yeah the sensors are
seeing so much yeah murder and child
abuse the burnout rate yeah you know
there's there was a tick tock contract
sure Tick Tock contracts to a third
party and they filed a class action
lawsuit for some reason I'm sure your
videos the third party filed one against
Tick Tock yeah for damages because they
say they just see terrible awful things
and they have to like they'll work part
of it is like they'll work really long
shifts right and then like without a
break from anything they're just taking
in all this terrible yeah it's not it
was 24 7 for me so I'd go in I'd look at
300 things I'd go out an hour later I'd
go back in look at another 100 things
stuff like that it says all day of my
life for five years it was that was my
life for those that are wondering why
Ian is the way he is he used to be
normal and he's looked at these things
and he became more and more Twisted I
did used to be normal
um I used to watch bangedup.com you ever
watch those old like oh Faces of Death
shows and stuff like in 2001 when the
internet was finally on and I could
finally watch a video I'd go on America
Online
um yeah it was I think I had America
online at the time and um and that was
like hard to watch but I was like
happens I should I should be able to see
it if it's going to happen in real life
I should see it but like that doesn't
mean I need to see every blown open body
yeah it's important for me to protect
the mind and uh I don't know how we're
gonna handle administrating these things
right this is the this is a big
challenge because there are evil people
posting evil stuff on all these
platforms and you know Elon of course
came in and that was a big thing he was
trying to do is get rid of this stuff
because Twitter certainly wasn't for
whatever reason thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time